yeah dude you got you got to wear this
dude you got to wear it you got to wear
it you got to wear it [__] yeah dude
yeah baby this bro what the hell that's
what I'm talking about dud that's what
I'm what was the story behind oh oh the
story's [__] good dude he stole that
[Music]
[__] all right we have a very very
special episode of careful boys right
now we got Jesus with
us the Del Taco lover the cool thing is
Jesus told us that he was a fan before
he even met us yeah it was is that
actually true 100% we did a gig together
we did a gig together at uh at a Long
Beach for like the sorority the agent
sorority and then you guys were all
there playing the band and thing we were
yeah I opened up we did remember when we
were the uncles and the
refugees yeah remember we did the the
the show there talk like oh your grandma
something like that like an
and he was mimicking some lady or some
and then uh yeah Long Beach Kelsey Long
Beach you don't remember that it we
busted a guitar out and I remember
playing but I remember damn I forgot how
many shows I remember that's when I met
you guys cuz they were like oh they're
the headliners I'm like who the [__] are
these guys and I thought that show was
hilarious cuz it's all improv I honestly
I was like oh these guys are [__]
funny and then I saw you guys I followed
you guys on YouTube and I'm like yo
these guys are really funny I like I
always liked what you guys were doing
and I knew you guys were like growing
and I try to mimic sometimes I got a
couple of Latino friends we should do
this look what they're doing but they
were like [__] that D okay we're funny D
I'm like yeah none of us none of us got
to do
anything I'm like all right well all
right so we're going to watch a um
Monumental throwback video and then uh
react to it if there's any commentary
you want to add cringe let me know and
then I'll pause it so you can say a few
words give us some insight I already
don't like this episode why
oh yeah look at that
chin ooh this is this the arrow this is
the ARA where I met met you
guys and this is oh [__]
loser show you right way the disco
dancing disco
dancing right away because everybody
they go to CL the was out of money on I
don't even know why even it so stupid
stand this is this is give us some give
us son's going to see this one day he's
already seen some of it he's going to
he's going to show up with that little
for context how how old are you guys
here we're like 22 and then you're at
whose house like Bart so this is Bart's
kitchen uh-huh by this time we already
created these characters Uncle chin and
Uncle Sam yeah and this is one of the
First videos that went viral for I UCLA
huh yeah that was right there yeah no
[__] and in the middle of like we would
meet up to go to study cuz we're both in
college and then somehow studying went
from an open textbook to us wearing
[__] outfits like this and recording
on a camera and I I and I remember I
think this idea came because we were
talking about why the [__] do Asians go
to the club but they don't dance like
they're just this is back in the day
before you guys came and made Asians
dance pre- stereotyp you remember that
[__] back in the day they would just buy
drinks and just stand and Wallflower and
just turn red and then we were
like and we were like we need to tell
them to [__] dance bro yeah but Asian
dancing is like by themselves too they
hate when somebody a girl's like can I
like it'sit
[__]
bro this one was TI like oh I like to I
like to learn that [__] they back the
[__] you better get the [__] away from
and it has to be organized and [__] yeah
she just like oh okay well I guess he's
[Laughter]
doing
gay I have a question you guys are
womanizers my thing is who what accent
are you imitating Vietnamese Vietnamese
first we used to do the Chinese one and
then we started doing the Vietnamese one
and we couldn't do the Chinese one no
more you guys switched permanently is
this improvised all improvised we so you
guys are just riffing right now yeah and
then probably after this we went back to
study yep
you see this pretty good improvise yeah
seriously who else beside this okay you
have to be original number one okay girl
like that number one girl like that now
you have to know the daning that's very
important the girl
oh my
God so you learning I think you learning
I know I see you yeah I want to
learn not I can see you doing
yes that's pretty good when you go
inside the CL just at cool you know cool
You Are So Co
so cool can you pause it real quick the
one of the craziest strips always is
knowing Joe from the other
picture yeah yeah yeah for Real where
did you make that
jump for both of you guys dude yeah yeah
yeah where do you go from like gang
banger to there was a hard long
transition it wasn't overnight yeah I
got you it wasn't overnight but the
funny thing is
I actually felt less gay uhhuh in a
character form because I was like I'm
playing a character this is me yeah so
that baldheaded Joe for some reason I
thought I was being less lame by doing a
character putting on a costume but by
myself I was too nervous to do comedy
got you but but was this a costume too
is what I'm saying well you being
another character there dude I'm a
studio gangster Studio gangster being
those characters was really freeing
because I think maybe like our whole
life we've been kind of like class
clowns but just the way that we were
brought up it didn't feel like we could
express ourselves so we're able to
express the side of ourselves through so
I like I I like I like this uh Back in
the Day stuff all right so myy what what
moment did you say like oh [__] this is
taking a different route where I should
quit
school cuz no we stayed in school like
lame ass that's why we're doing it ass
school really so you never left school
for that was our school apartment we
wanted to but we just we never really
like committed all the way cuz we're
still nervous we know what did you guys
graduate with like bachelor's degrees
you went to UCLA I went to calet LA and
you guys my thing
is my God my thing dude it's like if I
went to school as a mechanic and I was
like I'm a comic then why' you go to
mechanic school if you did you use this
degree not at all not at all because
college is where you find yourself oh
yeah we we we we sure found that we
found it in your [__] Thorn room I
was going to be a psychiatrist really
yeah so you're kind of in a way helping
people I'm a
businessman so when did you guys start
taking JK seriously what what video was
this is serious bro this is Ser yeah we
don't know we didn't know that we
thought this was serious so so this is
like super goofy right but you have to
understand during that time in YouTube
no one even believed in you
so as we were doing this we weren't even
getting paid to do this in our homie
Circle everyone thought oh B and is
going to go [__] around again make these
stupid videos like why don't we just all
go and [__] drink away our Friday
like we do usually and so we were like
from everyone around us from family
friends peers everyone that found out we
were doing YouTube videos they thought
we were outcasted it wasn't like oh [__]
I want to be a YouTuber now and people
like oh that's actual career it was more
like YouTubers didn't want to be
YouTubers back then being called a
YouTuber was like no oh no no I'm an
artist so then how did you know so how
who was the person that said we let's be
YouTubers let's do this let's or not
YouTubers but let's let's do this for
full time okay it was after college okay
so this we graduated 2009 there was no
jobs because of the crash so that
actually worked in our favor cuz I went
to work in shipping the [__] that I was
doing before College Bart was tutoring
kids and [__] and we're looking at each
other like sorry you spending time
tutoring [__] kids no like I really
think that it came as a blessing that
the economy crashed because I was like
if I if I got locked in with a job
because I had a degree and all that I
would have been [__] because I would
have never pursued YouTube I was like
well [__] this [__] sucks I'm getting
like 12 bucks an hour I might as well
just do YouTube then and that was the
that was the point and then Yahoo came
out with an article showing all the uh
top creators like Michelle Fawn Kev
Jamba uh Ryan hega and they're making
like a couple hundred thousand a year
that's so you said [__] it and we're
like oh my God a couple hundred th000
and like split between me and you that's
like $100,000 per person let's do it wow
back then it was like back then no one
was making millions on YouTube you know
was like early early but yeah cuz I I
moved out here 2009 uh ran into you guys
like
2010ish had to be like 201 10 around
that time yeah the first year I didn't
do anything yet so yeah 2010ish or 2011
yeah we're probably doing we're probably
doing YouTube full time then yeah and
then you were doing skits though when I
remember I remember you guys were doing
like little skits and then you do that
little character but you were a girl you
weren't a I was a pimp bro that's Uncle
chin that's not a girl are you talking
about Asian mom yes oh cuz you were like
look at that girl right there you said
something yeah you you making fun of
this girl in the audience saying like
look at that girl out there shaking
nasty I remember that stick to my mind
cuz I was like that's [__] hilarious
you're being their moms like yelling at
them at that school was to me was like
that's [__] hilarious it's like me
being a [__] bisa mom yelling at the
girls or and I'm like genius that's
[__] funny and it just like reminded
me so much of what my mom was it's our
16th year and I can't believe we never
did this but I got to bust out with a
[__]
merch Uncle Sam [__] it's
available now boom Bart this is for you
pass it around dude [__] awesome dude
[__] Uncle Sam go get it now we have
the link in the description box his name
was Uncle Sam Uncle CH yeah those are
our characters Uncle Sam yeah that the
reason why it's Uncle Sam is cuz he was
military so I thought it was funny to
call him uncle samon and the E is silent
wow you got to talk like Uncle Sam is
silent you got to hit me with an uncle s
spended in a video that the e was silent
for some reason oh it was that's the
joke this's crazy I don't even know if
it was a j I always thought that you
just pronounced it like same when you
did the accent I love I love everything
about that shirt that's [__] dope it
reminds you of juvenile's cover juvenile
yeah hey don't we have that that's my
favorite [__] face somewhere right
the bottom right is my favorite [__]
face dude this is great this is [__]
awesome oh my God you selling these
shirts you could get it right now you
could go click in the link description
oh dude those are Classics dude if you
don't get that shirt you're not a real
[__] OG JK news fans real F you're
not a real [__] fan the uncle chin
one is already out right now but then
this one we got to drop it cuz
everyone's like how you going to drop
one without the other that's true those
are facts also I love everything about
what you're doing right there that's
[__] awesome I I don't know why it
took us so long to actually make JK
merch with our dude you got you got to
wear this dude you got to wear it you
got to wear it you got to wear it [__]
yeah dude yeah baby got this bro what
the hell what talking what I'm talking
about I
haven't I haven't seen that's [__]
awesome I haven't seen that in like four
years that's [__] awesome dude or
five when's the last time you put that I
think guys brand everything at least
[__] 10 years maybe I have no idea
what was the story yeah yeah oh oh the
story's [__] good dude he stole that
[__] from where from where from like a
champ sports oh [__] it's even missing
an eye hey hey get this we did the most
Chinese [__] too after he was wearing
that thing and everyone's like where'
you get that hat we found out that they
don't even have it available so we got
that [__] made custom oh and then we
started selling it
oh do you remember like in high school
where like you and your homies with just
like have like a like a jack Fest
Jack steal well I had a different type
of Jack Fest but you're
stealing this was uh at stos high school
me and maybe like six of my homies at
the Long Beach town center there was a
Sport Chalet there we went there we
decided to just hit that one up I don't
know why we all stole [__] there's like
like six to 10 of us we all stole [__]
we got to the security and somehow they
I don't know if there was like a silent
alarm or whatever but it went off and
they pulled all of us into the security
room so everyone they start patting us
down my homie had like three hoodies on
snowboard jackets whatever I I stuffed
this in my crotch like this and this is
the only thing I stole so out of all my
friends I was the only one that was like
all you're good to go so it was kind of
like my lucky my lucky charm hat oh no
it's lucky and then so I iief so I I
stuffed this in my uh homies uh Civic
Muffler can I smell that after your done
I stuffed it in and I went back in and
I'm and I was standing there waiting
waiting for them and uh it became my
lucky my lucky charm hat I would wear it
when I would go snowboarding and all
that and when we were doing JK we're
just looking for the most ridiculous
[__] we have and I was like bro I have
this [__] weird ass hat that I stole
Fu That's History baby took it out and
at that time it was so old that one of
the eyes fell out so when we got these
custom made we told the factory like
yeah yeah we it's supposed to be just
one oh godam so great dude and when when
our when our fans when our fans got the
Hat they would all be like hey it's only
got one eye and like it's supposed to be
like that yeah look at the shirt dude
that's [__] it's missing only one eye
bro y only one eye awesome dude that's
funny dude I love everything and we have
a backstory about it too uh so in we
went our you also look a little mentally
challenged dude G me [__] you know R
ret he's got down syndrome yeah oh the
the character yeah you cuz you look like
an adult Down Syndrome guy mean like
kind of you're like this is like Asian
[__] uh uh night at the rockberry you
know what I mean these guys are clubbing
guys you know so the backstory is we're
brothers and we got abandoned by our
parents in an amusement park and our
parent bought that for him that hat so
that's why he keeps he keeps it on him
to see if they're going to be one day
like oh that's our [__] [__]
kid and then they they that's why he
can't he can't let it go oh that's dark
but also very dark yeah it's very
[__] of you um I love everything
about this character that's why he's got
a suit on dude okay guys I'm going to
throw something out there dude all right
throw it out there throw it out there I
know you guys can do it now and this
needs to be done guys how about [__]
the movie of these two guys a movie of
these two guys come on dude modern day
modern day
these guys out here Uncle Sam Uncle chin
things that they can't say you can't say
that you can't do that you guys are
trying to be Club [__] owners come on
baby this to be a [__] movie I could
be the pis guy that helps you can't do
that gay guy and then [__] dude
that's [__] awesome that would be
cool Finance it do it Finance it you're
going to have a Pisa character you're
going to have a Pisa character I you're
the club owner you own the chest out I
like this guys F hey Mr [__] I like
the guy and we're trying to throw a
party at your Club yes yes yes I'm just
like oh for sure dude come on you know
we should put a GoFundMe fin ass only if
you wear the cowboy boots with the curly
to that's the only way I'm going to do
it baby if you do okay I would be that
character dude chest out [__] you
know what I mean dude how hilarious is
that we hire a couple of [__] dancers
[__] trying
to in in instead of girl go go dancers
we have these guys just
[__] I'm telling you baby yeah what
the [__] I think that would be great I
think it needs to be done dude I think
people want to see these characters
freak Show baby baby on the Dance Floor
oo that'll be dope and their favorite
music is Funk yeah it's their favorite
yeah this is this is a movie guys I
didn't know there was so much more to
the character huh I didn't know there
was that much lower to these character
oh yeah dude that there was any death at
all it was so easy I didn't think that
that the dude was down syndrome I made
that part let me tell you something
there's a lot of backstory though we
would just discuss random things like
that before you even press play I'm like
oh yeah he's the [__] and this is the
brother that's kind of guiding him
through life a little bit in a wrong way
he influenced them the wrong way you
know what I mean that's [__] great
dude let watch there's just a little bit
left super sex out this one from the
ancient
watch out the demo the
demo do you have dude you got gloves on
guys you have gloves on dude you have
gloves on and sword he [__] charged
up to dance
Too about the ear he had to rev himself
up bro this is sick the thing is that
Gio watched it and said I want to hear
that guy I want to make a baby with that
guy that's the weirdest
part he just walk I like that one the
classic 8s
move can you pause it real quick I think
in the other room I had a regular just
roommate you did a regular a regular
roommate just probably just trying to
study and isn't he like a dentist now
he's a pharmacist now and he's like he's
like oh yeah I think Bart's friend is
just going to come over and shoot some
videos he's dude he's probably right now
in [__] he like wondering what
happened to you guys you guys probably
didn't do [__] with your lives is
[__] funny dude I love it dude in the
other room that's the character has like
that like uh problem like if you try to
take the little hat off he doesn't want
to he's
like something about Mary you
know [__] funny that guy was never
complaining about you guys making noise
and stuff wow what a we would practice
our characters in his room while he's
studying I don't know why like he would
be like we could be in Bart's room but
he's on the computer and we're in his
room acting like Korean uncles he need
an audience I remember I remember the
day that our Korean accent clicked I
think he was was actually in bed uh
sleeping and we're at the foot of his
bed at 2:00 a.m. and then me and Joe are
like oh oh but mck oh they sound like
this and then we and and we're just L
the our my room's empty the living
room's empty we're just in his room and
we're not even talking to him this's
trying to sleep hey uh I try I got an
early exam
tomorrow I remember hey he's a down ass
friend man he's AOL dude it be pretty
sick if you guys just go to the L what
if you just [__] your guys's guts
behind your back he just was like I
[__] hate these cars that's [__]
awesome he had a knife under the cover
just waai like when you sleep
[__] yeah dude he's all sleep
deprived he's just he's like Joe's got
to pay rent man that's a crazy story
dude man [__] that
[__] that's so true just look at us two
so sexy
guy every time
we always always so we don't toach you
cuz we know a black guy the white guy
the Mexican guy they always get the Girl
Stolen oh my God that comes from that
comes from anger within the real part
not this
character going on peace and then you
went straight back to studying y get
shirts now everybody that loved us H
yeah dude I can't wait to get to some of
them shirts hey uh oh by the way as
Vietnamese uh uh do they sound like
Vietnamese people I mean it's just as
annoying yeah yeah yeah okay gotcha all
right you you guys [__] did it hey
shout out shout out to Miss Peach who uh
had one of the most recent comments on
this video and said 2023 still funny
still following these fools they've come
a long way look at look at their
apartment and look at them now wow
thanks Miss Peach just kidding news
careful boys is a brand just kidding
news is the man of smart people the
people of just kidding news careful boys
they are very smart just kiding news the
number one foodcast in the
[Music]
world